hey guys Pete here picking up with my
mr. robot season 1 re-watch this will be
my recap and review for episode 5
episode 5 is called exploits and when
you think about it that's what this show
is all about we've talked about Damon's
running in the background we've talked
about bugs we've talked about how that
all relates to the things that you hide
from other people weaknesses if you will
so it's all about vulnerabilities and we
can call those exploits right we can
call that how people use the things are
part of you against you and we see this
play out on a human level in this
episode it's another strong episode in
my opinion it does contain one part of
the first season that I didn't like as
much as some of the other parts and
that's the Fernando of era of stuff but
it all makes sense and fits in pretty
well in the final product
in this episode we would learn more
about his situation he basically did the
opposite of what Elliott would do and
that's he put everything all of his
business online and social media in a
code that wasn't that hard to crack his
little brother gave him the idea so his
little brother is out there trying to
right the situation and we find out that
Vera's definitely in trouble he's going
to be doing time his lawyer saying
there's no deal on the table so he wants
to avoid Supermax and he basically says
you know what if they lock me up it
doesn't matter where the bars are and in
this process he realizes that Elliott is
the one who tipped him off there's a
photograph there we see on the table and
that gives things away we get a little
bit of his worldview I guess you could
say there is we hear him say this thing
of making it right with the universe
he says that's how we get square with
the universe and so we get the idea that
trailer is in trouble because to this
point she's the only one who's actually
broken through Elliott's defenses on the
human level and his kind of thinking is
going to be to get even with Elliott by
getting to her we learned in the past
episode that they're going to try to
breach
security at steel mountain we see that
plan play out as they're driving up
Elliot sees that their tagline is
impenetrable he says nothing is actually
impenetrable a place like this says it
is and it's closed but people still
built this place and if you can hack the
right person all of a sudden you have a
piece of powerful malware people always
make the best exploits in the themes of
this show there are things that I think
are absolutely profound and one of those
is the way that Elliot tells us he's
never had trouble hacking people he's
never had trouble picking up on their
weaknesses and what I think is really
interesting about that is that he has no
idea we saw in the last episode that he
has no idea what his own monster is his
own weaknesses are he has clues as to
certain things but it's just one of
those life things you know you can see
what other people are struggling with
what they can't see past but it's not so
easy with yourself so he runs into Bill
Harper who is a pretty unsuspecting
character when we meet him and he is the
guy that Elliot has to get through to
get out of level 1 into level 2 or he
can put in the Raspberry Pi and let's
face it bill never stood a chance
against Elliot and it's a pretty brutal
scene whenever this goes down he tells
him think about it bill if you died
would anyone care and you know we get
those shots of the background of his
Instagram account that has a few
pictures of him and his cat and it's a
pretty good setup and it's just as you
feel terrible for Bill at the end if
you're human I guess but he is a perfect
weakness for what needs to happen things
don't go exactly smoothly but one thing
leads to another and Elliot finds
himself on level two of course where he
gets there things aren't set up the
right way so he ends up going back down
and then he ends up running into Tyrell
now this is a little bit too convenient
for my taste but they explain why
they're there the big actual reveal here
is that
Tyrell tells him he knows that he set up
Terry Colby he doesn't have proof he
can't prove it but he knows that it's
his doing and he's not going to turn him
in I think what kind of makes this work
is some of the actual camera work that's
involved and I'm not an expert so I'm
not going to pretend like I can tell you
why I just think that when we're
watching the bill scene and we're
watching some of these interactions
between Tyrell and Elliot that it
there's a mood that's set by the way
that things are depicted and I think it
works really well like I said it seems a
little too convenient to Tyrell would be
there and that Elliot would be able to
get access as a result of Tyrell being
there but it goes along with what we're
talking about here mr. robots whispering
in his ear that Tyrells weakness is his
strength
it's his hubris the way that he wants to
be recognized for his greatness and
that's how Elliot does what he does I
mean there's some really funny parts
throughout this sequence of events at
steel mountain and you know where Elliot
just doesn't do anything or he does
something that would be otherwise
ridiculous but because the other systems
are in place like his web page that says
that he's a billionaire and whatever it
all seems to work out it's kind of
interesting to look back when we talked
about the last episode we talked about
the different weaknesses that the
different people had so I won't rehash
them all here we see I think there I
think there's a conscious effort to show
us some of the differences about Tyrell
and Elliot Tyrell mentions that these
two guys that he was talking to or
financed years of Hezbollah and Isis and
he kind of puts down the waiter who has
served him you know that's the most
important thing that he has to do is
give him a salad I thought the scene
where Elliot's sitting there in the cops
or the security guards come up and he's
I mean he looks really afraid there and
then he goes off to the bathroom and
throws up rah I mentioned it before and
I'll mention it again rami malek does a
really great job in the series all
together but anyways as he is in the
bathroom throwing up he realizes that he
is on level two now this whole thing
worked
how he had hoped and he installs the
Raspberry Pi before Tyrell comes in to
interrupt him when Tyrell does come in
he drops a bit of a truth bomb like I
said he talks about the Colby thing but
he also says that Elliot's bug or his
monster he mentions his father he
mentions his father dying and so that is
an indication that Tyrell is pretty good
at hacking people as well even though it
looks like in this round
Elliott wins because he's able to put
the Raspberry Pi in place just to finish
up the idea about Terry Colby the reason
why he doesn't care to turn him in is
because Terry Colby not being an evil
Corp anymore serves him and his chance
to be able to move up the ladder we
later see him go back to New York City
and they have dinner with the next CTO
Sharon and Scott Knowles we see Joanna
in her native element working the room
working everybody there we see a strange
interaction with Tyrell when he goes
into the bathroom and she kind of yields
to him in a way and then he just walks
out and one of the big things that comes
out during the dinner was that Tyrell
knows that he's going to be the CTO he
knows that Scott Knowles is going to be
the CTO and that information he got from
monitoring the phone and really he
shouldn't have it Scott Knowles knows he
shouldn't have it so even though
everything goes right at steel Mountain
and they pull off what they needed to
pull off there there's still another
part that goes wrong for F Society and
that's the idea that Darlene isn't able
to bring the dark army on board we see
her get kicked from the RC channel and
banned and then we see her track down
Cisco who tells her that it's over leave
it alone and we learned that even Cisco
doesn't know why they won't help but he
doesn't seem to think they can be
brought around and that ends up at Coney
Island with Darlene about to go ahead
with the hack anyways even though
everyone in the room knows that it won't
do any good because everything they
destroy is backed up in China after mr.
robot isn't able to do so
Eliott able to would like talk her off
the ledge I guess you could say he says
that they'll figure out something he
doesn't know what it is but for today
that everything's over I think one of
the my favorite parts of the episode on
rewatch is when he talks to Shayla over
the phone I never noticed how much he
was positively affected by her of course
when he gets back we see that she's been
kidnapped her phone is there and he
talks to Vera on the phone but yeah it's
clear here that he did what he had to do
he talked to her on the phone when she
called he smiles she makes him happy she
has broken through his defenses and that
makes it a little bit more devastating
when she gets sucked up at the end
Angela does actually leave Ollie and we
see her go out to stay with her father
she finds out that he still owes a lot
of money to evil Corp because of her
mother's illnesses for insurance
payments she goes for a run late at
night and we see her kind of
soul-searching as to how to move forward
after leaving the city and finding out
this information there's some funny
there was a couple funny parts in this
that are political I guess but Shayla
tells a lie about being a pharmaceutical
rep rather than being a drug dealer and
at her new job and the girl says oh that
must have been nice she must have made
Bank what happened and she says says oh
you know Obamacare it was his pretty
funny when you think about it because
that's the kind of lie you can tell that
people will believe this because they
don't really know anything about it but
yeah I overall pretty good episode
things are moving and I can't wait to
what's the next one so I'm gonna finish
this now so let me know what you think
in the comments of this video please
like it if you enjoyed it please think
about visiting my patreon and getting
involved over there make sure you
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and turn on notifications so
you'll see when new videos are released
follow me on social media twitter
instagram and facebook we can interact
over there and i'll be finishing this up
before season 3 starts so check back
soon
thanks for watching guys
talk to you again